what's up guys I'm Lucy and I'm tomorrow
we here at Gamescom 2016 celebrating the
games for more specifically was
celebrating the VR games kind of kind of
yeah but I mean it feels like you know
you saying that he felt like oculus
maybe wasn't focusing on a game unit you
think about when vive got announced and
it was more focused on really
experiences like the deep I'm like til
crush now we're getting the games yeah
games coming thick and fast for VR we've
been playing a bunch of them yeah the
one I want to spend like when I went to
my appointment I was like I can't think
of many oculus games that really stand
out for me and then I played Wilson's
heart which was quite interesting you it
feels like a lot of games that we're
getting right now this kind of
first-person horrors kind of tension
focused puzzle games yeah so like you're
walking around this kind of hospital and
you're trying to figure out what's going
on but the key part of my my experience
was the touch controllers it's the first
time I've used the touch control it's
not out yet but it's coming out very
soon and I think that becomes a gateway
to more traditional gaming experiences
or like bigger more interesting depth
gaming experiences so like I with the
touch controller I was picking up a lot
of balls and I wasn't doing what I'm
supposed to be doing I'm just kind of
using it as an experiment for the
controller and it's really cool you can
control fingers like individually so I
was picking things up and like throwing
them around and the lady given our demo
was just like this is not how this is
supposed to be played and at one point I
was just kind of testing a fidelity of
it and I was juggling at one point and
it actually worked pretty well like I'm
not good at juggling so it was like whoo
and I managed to catch here but like
someone who's good at juggling could I
can conceive you know to do the juggling
thing that kind of fidelity it almost
it's not a controller yeah it
almost kind of like a controller I feel
like it gives me some more control over
VR games the kind of control that I
would want as a console pc traditional
type gamer okay well I was on the fly I
played a bunch game so I played a
serious Sam in VR which was way more
intense than I was anticipating I did
not like my arms are hurting at the end
of it because you're not just shooting
at the ground you're shooting yeah
really quickly really intense but it
also had a shocking like when they come
in you know when you're playing the
Bible you see you have like the grid
around you so you don't bump into walls
and stuff and you think that you're kind
of gonna be safe
because you have that grid but when the
characters like come towards you and the
screens going red because they're being
hit it's quite scary another game that I
played which was really cool and it was
very very sci-fi was a space pirate
trainer yeah and they gave us some
awesome mixed rally footage of those so
you can see like what it was like for me
are you standing in the middle of like
this training zone on these drones are
coming firing at you you can fire back
at them which is also making of you know
sort of do kill with skills actually
Bulletstorm that but you know what I
mean it's like it was more fun and it
was more engaging than this being in an
experience where you're just watching
something and we played the Batman
Beyond yeah Sirians I guess yeah and we
love that but I thought this was this
was more like additional their
traditional games I've been back at an
arcade again but obviously more yeah I
guess like I do my oculus appointment I
spoke to Jason Rubin who is the
co-founder of Naughty Dog and worked at
THQ for a while so he's been making
games for a long long time he's a very
traditional game developer and designer
and he's head of studios at oculus right
now and that's one of the questions I
asked him I asked him like are we ever
gonna get to the point where we'll be
able to play a Skyrim type experience
and games on the oculus vive and even
places should be awesome what it will
feel less like tech demos and more like
fully fledged games and he thinks that
we're gonna get there pretty quickly
like developers are very quickly
figuring out the issues that prevent
happening right now and he was like I
reckon like it's going to be the
dominant form a dominant form of gaming
with in like less than ten years I mean
and that doesn't very long that's a
couple of generations of a console I
mean a console generation can lost
between four and eight years for the
coronation
four or five years let's say so yeah I
think we've got a quite I'm more
optimistic about VR than I was when I
went in partly because of Batman I think
PlayStation VR gets a lot of credibility
by you know linking itself to franchises
and and just being tied to Playstations
and I think oculus are doing quite well
pushing the game stuff like the
traditional mechanic heavy game stuff
with the with the touch controller and
Bible you know they're doing really
interesting experiential things like
it's still quite expensive for me that
is probably the one thing that is a
barrier to me a moment is yeah of course
but obviously how the tech gets better
yeah the price to come down it's more
accessible my interest in it has kind of
like raised after this event so for more
on everything you from games come 2016
make sure of course stay tuned to games